[Music]
hey what's up I'm Kim PhD here so you
know those fish that suction themselves
to sharks and you always see them along
the side of sharks like they follow the
shark everywhere they go swimming
alongside it usually attached to it it's
called The remora fish and they are
fascinating creatures they have this
relationship that's kind of amazing for
the Remora it gets to snack on the
scraps of whatever the shark is eating
and it has a 24 7 bodyguard basically
and a shark allows it to do that because
it'll also eat parasites off the shark's
back keeps it clean it's a win-win they
have a symbiotic relationship meaning
they both benefit but really really
there are more fish definitely needs the
shark way more than the other way around
so you never really see them out in the
wild without some sort of host or
something to attach to now in the tech
world
apple is that shark and there are a
whole bunch of companies you've probably
heard of them whose primary business
function happens to be an accessory that
attaches to something Apple does and
that is a dangerous place to live so
this whole dynamic is it's so
fascinating to watch because there's so
many examples of it now of course air
tags is you know the one recent
announcement that's got me thinking a
lot about this lately but really anytime
Apple enters a new product category it
gets a lot of attention because it's
interesting like how will Apple do it
the apple way will they separate
themselves from the competition or do
anything technically different and air
tags they have some legitimately unique
features the little Precision find
feature makes for a cool demo but
Bluetooth trackers are not new not even
close uh tile has been making these
things since 2013 and they do
fundamentally the same thing they help
you find whatever they're attached to by
pinging other phones around that have
the Tile app which creates the community
mesh Network and help you find your
thing plus there's a couple other
features and a variety of shapes and
sizes and tiles also built in to some
other items but for the core function of
finding your thing
air tags have a massive Advantage which
is their network isn't just people using
the Tile app it's all the stuff on
Apple's find my network so it's iPhones
it's iPads it's Max and they'll all
passively update the position of
something near it anytime it's around a
device on that Network it's frictionless
it happens silently and effortlessly in
the background you don't even know
what's happening and the network is
massive it's approaching a billion
devices so there are some best case
estimates that put tile's presence in
some of the most densely populated
cities in the world like Manhattan and
San Francisco at one tile user per block
meaning you can't go more than a block
without encountering a tile that will
update the location on the network which
is pretty impressive but when you think
about those same blocks in those same
cities you're gonna get what a dozen
plus iPhones and Macs and iPads and
that's not even considering all of the
other less populated areas so
immediately Lee Apple's ability to plug
a feature into the iPhone gave them a
huge advantage over the competition that
is the theme so I already made a video
called the Apple ecosystem explained
I'll link it below the like button if
you haven't seen it already but I talk
about why people keep choosing the
iPhone just because of the walls around
the ecosystem but here's another thought
because of Apple's ability to plug
things into the ecosystem especially
with the iPhone Apple can kill entire
companies but they don't do it
menacingly they do it so nicely by
presenting it as a choice on a silver
platter less than a month ago Apple
actually opened up the find my network
to allow third-party accessories to take
advantage of this incredible Network
right so out of the gate there were
e-bikes and earbuds and conveniently and
other cheap plastic Bluetooth tracker
that you can find based on nearby
devices in this network amazing so now
for tile there's technically a choice
you can make a tile that's compatible
with Apple's find my network
or not
it's a choice pretty simple
but it's actually a bit of a paradox of
choice because either way you choose
Apple still wins so let's say they
choose to make a compatible tile that
works in the find my iOS ecosystem that
seems great right it works great for the
users they take advantage of that better
network but now that means a portion of
new tile customers who were going to buy
a regular tile that plugs into and
improves the tile network will actually
be plugging into and improving Apple's
network instead the plug-in to find my
and they won't use the Tile app for
locating a device which means now tile
is selling a product that actively hurts
their own business and makes their own
network less desirable over time so the
other choice is to not participate in
the find my network and not offer a tile
that works with it
which just means you're missing out on
those sales and they're less appealing
Network slowly dies over time as people
just buy the ones with the more deeply
compatible iPhone but hey technically
it's a choice
right look look how friendly this guy is
he would he would never force you to do
anything he didn't want to
you can just you can choose to work with
the iPhone or not
it's up to you
could also choose to swim off into the
rest of the ocean
or you could stay swimming with me the
shark
makes sense right I'd actually argue
this Paradox of choice happens twice
with air tags so once with Kyle as we
just saw but also again for the customer
so if you're an iPhone user now
technically you have a choice between
the two different options which one is
going to require a separate app and has
a much smaller Network and the other
just kind of plugs right in and
seamlessly works in the background and
not much thought to it and they're
around the same price
see what I'm getting at now apple apple
will always repeat day in and day out
there is competition we have competition
and you can always choose our
competition over the product we make
but Apple's smart so obviously they know
they have deep Market penetration with
the iPhone
and so when they want to leverage that
to jump into a new product category
they'll do it every time they've done it
before Apple watch is maybe the most
popular watch on Earth I think they've
said this before and airpods are
honestly some of the most popular
wireless earbuds ever made that's
because of the iPhone but it's even more
fascinating when they literally kill
whole companies like when the shark
decides to close its mouth and eat the
fish that was cleaning its teeth Apple's
done this so many times I've got four
more examples for you uh each one of
them a little bit more brutal than the
last so I'm going to rank them on a
scale of one to ten one being a light
scratch 10 being absolutely finished on
how bad apple left them after they
jumped into the new product category and
if you'll notice they're all on the back
of this Paradox of choice so flux or F
dot Lux you might have heard of them
they are an app that lets you change the
color temperature of your screen right
so it'll adjust to have more or less
blue light output and it can
automatically make your screen warmer
and dimmer the later it gets in the day
flux used to be in Apple's app stores
but then in 2015 they were kicked out
and Apple's reasoning was developers
can't take advantage of the use of
certain private apis so it seems
reasonable we all know Apple's been very
specific about the way you know Macs and
iPhones and iPads should look and feel
but what feels weird about that one
specifically is later that year Apple
came out with an update or they built in
that exact functionality into the OS
themselves
it's on the Mac behind me it's called
night shift so with night shift your
iPhone or iPad or Mac can get warmer or
cooler based on the time of day or where
you're at and it can set a schedule for
when you want that to happen super
useful of course and convenient now that
it's baked in so now you're a Mac User
you've got a choice you can you can go
to the flux website and download it
since it's not in the App Store anymore
and then approve it through security and
then set it up and get the schedule
going
or you can just use the one built into
system preferences
but she have a choice I'm giving this
one a 5 out of 10 only because Apple
could only kill half the company when
it's also available on Windows and on
Android if you root but also Android's
added some of this functionality Windows
10 has added some of this functionality
so all of them combined would make it
about a 10 out of 10 but Apple could
only kill half all right so then there
are iPad styluses and this isn't one
company so much as it's like a whole
product category that sort of got
pummeled when Apple decided to enter so
there's a big Variety in this space
there's the markers and pens and pencils
and styluses that can all write on the
iPad Surface and so you can get anything
from Ultra cheap to Ultra Premium
depending on what you want it to do and
then Apple just drops in at the high end
with the apple pencil now the apple
pencil as we all know works with and
plugs into the iPad Pro better than any
other stylus I would say literally
because of the first gen apple pencil
but no other iPad Pro stylus slaps onto
the side of the iPad pad magnetically
and pairs instantly and charges while
sitting there it works with all of iPad
os's built-in tools and minimizes
latency with that high refresh rate
display it is the best possible
implementation of an iPad Pro input
device plus I can imagine in future
versions of the apple pencil having a U1
chip right it would make a lot of sense
you can add it to the find my network
you can direct your iPhone to find it
when you lose it we all know we've lost
that pencil before there's just no way
to justify buying a different stylus for
100 bucks for the iPad
I mean you can
you have that choice so I'm going to
give this one like a six six or seven
just because you can still buy the
cheaper ones if you just want a very
simple input device normal stylus but
the second you go 100 bucks plus that
whole category
really hard to compete with the apple
pencil so okay then there's duet display
so you might not have heard of this one
but you probably have heard of sidecar
the feature right that lets you use your
iPad as a second display for your Mac
what you might not know is duet display
is an app and a company that's been
built to do exactly this for a long time
much before a sidecar existed and just
like flux you know it still exists still
got Windows and Android and even Chrome
OS versions and it actually does still
work for iPad but you can imagine most
people who are just searching for
something on Google like how to use an
iPad as a second display sidecar is
going to come up the majority of the
time and it's going to be the easiest
way to do it plugging straight into iPad
OS the majority of the time so duet
display does have a couple extra
features on top of sidecar like you you
can use the touch screen while you're
mirroring but still like flux and like
tile
but most people are just going to be
satisfied with the first party built-in
version so I'm going to give this a
seven because there's still the windows
users with iPads we're still going to
make that happen so last but not least
there is Watson
and this one probably hurts the most so
this was a Search tool in the Mac that
let you search the web and and search
all kinds of other things without
actually having to open up your browser
and their tagline was actually an
Innovative utility that bypasses the web
browser but as you probably already know
Apple came out with Sherlock 3 which was
then called a spotlight which is in
everything they make now I use it all
the time and it does exactly the same
thing search the web search your Mac
search whatever also the Mac does it the
iPhone does it the iPad does it Android
phones do it like you can still
technically choose to download This
original but look at their website like
you can imagine there hasn't been a good
reason for people to download Watson in
a long time if this is what their
website still looks like that that I'm
going to say is a 10 out of 10 rip
completely gone right alongside like the
flashlight app you remember those when
you used to be able to download a
flashlight app on the iPhone then Apple
literally built it into the lock screen
on iOS and now there's no reason to
download a flashlight app I mean you can
choose to
technically
but you're not going to so all this is a
dynamic I encourage you to pay attention
to the shark and the Remora of the tech
world right and there's a lot of this
talk going on in in the public sphere
already with the the whole Anti-Trust
and the Walled Garden talks funny enough
the day after air tags were announced
tile testified in front of Congress to
explain how Apple was leveraging an
unfair advantage to enter that market
but of course Apple would argue no we
didn't
we let people choose we gave people a
choice everyone had a choice you could
plug in to the find my network if you
wanted to or not that's up to you you
can do it the apple way or not and
whichever product people decide to buy
so be it so I don't think there's any
correct answer there's no easy right
answer but what do you think should
Apple not be allowed to plug into their
own ecosystem and leverage that to make
new great products or does Apple have
too much power in that way but I
encourage you to pay attention to when
Apple inevitably enters even more new
product categories like when they make
an AR headset or a camera or whatever
other new product they do end up making
watch how much they plug in to that
ecosystem in ways that their competition
literally can't and watch how those fish
respond to the shark but either way it's
crazy to think about how far Apple has
come from being a small company out of a
garage to literally one of the biggest
companies ever to exist mostly on the
backs of the iPhone speaking of which my
friend Renee Ritchie also he's made a
nebula original on the introduction of
that original iPhone with a bunch of
Industry folks including myself talking
about you know the fact that that made
such huge Ripples and the first keynote
and what that original iPhone meant so
you can watch that whole thing on nebula
a video streaming service built by
independent creators including myself
and that is bundled with this video's
sponsor curiosity Stream So nebula is
already pretty dope there's a lot of the
smartest creators I know on their minute
physics Tech alter Renee Ritchie as I
mentioned all using nebula to share
their best stuff and sometimes even
trying new stuff that doesn't quite work
on YouTube so I've been putting my
videos on nebula ad free so you're
welcome for the info on how to watch the
videos without sponsors as a sponsor
it's getting pretty meta but besides
that Curiosity stream is a subscription
service sort of built to like my exact
tastes it's a home to all kinds of
thousands of documentaries and shows
about technology and futurism and
culture and invention and the Social Web
all that kind of stuff just look at this
category drop down on the site I mean
that's pretty amazing I feel like I'm
perfectly in the Target demographic and
if you watch my videos or enjoy them you
probably would like these too there's
one called Shark family tree which looks
at how incredible great white sharks are
they're all in 4k there's also plenty
more where I can learn way too much
about sharks so I encourage you to check
them out so since the two together are
kind of a no-brainer you can use my code
or the link below to get both nebula and
curiosity stream bundled together I have
a feeling I'm going to be recommending a
lot more of this stuff in the future
either way that's been it again let me
know what you think of the Apple Paradox
of choice I'll talk to you guys in the
next one
peace
[Music]